[Music]
[Applause]
David Spade's podcast with Dana Carvey
called fly on the wall where Saturday
Night Live alumni take a behind the
scenes reminisce about the most
memorable moments and uh they're friends
of the show you can find it I heart
radio it's the podcast of the Year award
it's up for that how about variety's
best new podcast and the 25th
anniversary of Chris Farley's death his
friends Dana Carvey and David Spade
hosted a special two-part tribute on
their fly on the wall podcast uh Chris
Rock Adam Sandler Conan O'Brien Mike
Myers we're all featured who came up
with the idea to uh do a 25th
anniversary
uh it sort of crept up from the fans
that were writing in saying all right
what are you gonna do for this because
you know obviously Chris comes up in a
lot of stories about SNL and we have
different hosts on or
different cast members so but we haven't
had a show about him and you know we've
done about
50 60 shows so I didn't know that this
was like a big anniversary it just seems
like way yeah it's it's see it's 25
years and I would have guessed 15 I
don't know you know those things just
yeah I don't know if I block it out or
what but I knew it was December and um
and then we just said hey the last one
of the year maybe we should do that and
it turned into two episodes because
you know uh when we contacted some of
the old friends of his and people that
were around and you know like a movie
producer or his mom or just we're trying
to sort of make it more of a wide net
and more people wanted to do it then we
could actually bring in so we just
started it and then it went too long so
we did another one and then we just
stopped but
it's it was an interesting you know
interesting for for a newer generation I
think is nice too A lot of people don't
even know him anymore you know that
that's sort of a
problem with me being 75 years old is
that uh there's you know I try to brag
about things and no one even knows I I I
wondered how much you wanted to do this
where you take a trip down memory lane
because you you've shared stories about
Chris but
I mean it's got to be painful as well
yeah I mean you
you keep it on a surfacy level because I
have to say it might cross the line
every single day there there's a for
different reasons and you get yourself
to not be sad about it you know I had a
best friend when I was 21 died in a car
accident
and that really rocked me because no one
really had died in my life you know and
then suddenly everyone's dropping it was
like my stepdad and then another friend
at school and then
and then someone committed suicide and
so I started to go oh this is like I'm
not even that old I was 21 20 I'm like
this can happen around you and so you're
never quite brace for it and then Chris
was a really big one and so
I don't try to get to the level I think
people bring them up a lot to me of
course and uh it's always positive and
people are always happy to talk about
them
um I think in the podcast there's waves
where almost everybody chokes up like
there's waves where we joke we try to
keep it light but he just can't help it
you know and I think you guys talk about
he was unhatable I think you talked
about that I think Chris said that yeah
yeah everybody everybody loved Farley
what for those who may not be as
familiar with Chris Farley yeah how
would you describe
a jolly
a a a a a one of the big physical
comedians likable lots of different
funny moves uh great voice
um
very sweet guy from Wisconsin
that you know uh tried to emulate the
old SNL greats he was a big Belushi fan
big awkward fan and Bill Murray and you
know um when he got one time we realized
he was wearing Belushi's pants in a
sketch in the back it says Belushi you
know they write it in of like who's
wardrobe and ward has been there the
whole time so we were both sort of
freaking out going oh my God these are
his
and you can find a sketchy word so he
kept them and then he would wear them
under his regular monster sized pants
and um and I go I don't know if you can
do that I don't know physically you can
and he goes no no this is good luck this
is Belushi the guy and so we have Jim
Belushi on the podcast and that's where
it got more emotional because
it's his brother now this is one of my
best friends and all of us that we
talked on the show we're very close to
him but when you get Jim talking with
his brother John and how John was
Chris's Idol and Jim had to shake Chris
and say you can't you're gonna die you
can't do this this ended badly for my
brother I don't want it to happen again
and
you know people that are that are on uh
addicted things and all that you know
you you people say why don't you help
them I mean I spent years it just they
they resent you at a certain point so it
leads to friction you know but Jim was
very sweet actually to come on and and
dig because it got emotional with him of
course
yeah and I know you've talked about that
that it's like hey you saw it happening
in front of you but yeah it it didn't
matter like I wasn't going to listen to
you and he said like Jim said John
Belushi uh Little People if they don't
know of course they really don't know
John
he was just another great that we grew
up with that we couldn't believe so cool
and funny and when he uh he had a
different set of friends at the end and
I think that's was part of the
disconnect with all of us with Chris you
know if Even Adam would go see him you
know he's like he's with a couple guys I
didn't know you know that that's what
happens oh yeah you just have when we
walked on the street and somewhere and
go hey and it's like 1am we have to work
the next morning and on the streets in
New York people like Spade barley hey
have a drink with us and he'd go okay
and we're like oh and then even the
people were like I was sort of kidding
and then he climbs over the little bear
hey I'm in a scoot over and then I'm
like oh okay I'll see it work but anyway
to get mad if you didn't finish your
drink like we'd be at a table and he
would block me and go you finished that
goddamn drink we're working in six hours
I I'm already drunk no no and so he'd go
around the table and just slam
everybody's drink and then leave him and
I go okay we have a situation here how
many outtakes are there from Tommy Boy
um Tommy Boy was you were almost
deliriously tired uh the good news is
they weren't really on our ass like they
are in movies now they just said these
two are kind of funny shove them up to
Toronto and let's just see what happens
and so everyone's kicking in jokes no
one's saying no but how much of a script
did you have for Tommy Boy we had a
script you know it's a script about
brake pads which is really not
hysterical but I mean that's we could
never pitch it is it the greatest brake
pad movie it is one of the best okay all
right all right one of the best one of
the top yeah
about Ohio and brake pad combo and sales
and so we would just say hey this
scene's a little flat you know what if
you had a clip-on tie we mentioned that
or let's do that housekeeping joke we do
in the hotel or let's do your fat guy in
the code you just bore me with every day
and so we would work those in not
knowing and that's that was us learning
later that the deer in the back seat if
you've seen the movie was the highest
testing part of the movie and 10 years
later it's not the number one thing to
think about it's just jokes and little
scenes and lines you know I would think
that you know the ripping your support
no those are those are bigger overall
down the line but when you test an
audience to see if they're laughing
right that second that one takes a
couple viewings to seep in
when your hair flies back
well okay so that one I said it might be
too corny if I'm super bald so we did we
did one where you know you have to put a
bald cap on everyone thinks I'm still
bald you know fine
I took it for the movie I took them to
the team but then you have to put a wig
over your bald cap which takes two hours
and then it didn't look real enough so
we had to fly back to goddamn Toronto
one more time to say I said it is worth
it I hate it but if it's for a joke I
will do it but I don't want to but I go
okay let's just go full monty bald head
like let's just and then he's a huge fan
I don't know it turned out really funny
um and there's one where roblo's shirt
we talked to him where it sucks off his
body and I was there watching that day
and then I went I left I go how are they
even gonna do that they did it with a
wire and stuff and it looks so hilarious
I couldn't believe it we're talking to
David Spade uh yeah you are the podcast
with Dana Carvey is called fly on the
wall I was watching John Candy in Planes
Trains the other day oh my God yeah yeah
and I and I I
I don't think he embraced his size as
part of his humor whereas Chris yeah and
I wondered if Chris
regretted that that it it became more
physical that you know would he have
become like a John Candy type of
comedian
I think I think he would have toned it
down because he wanted to do more
dramatic stuff and uh I think he would
have had to you can't you know you can't
just fall through tables at all times
but John Candy was similar in the way
very lovable very uh very fun thing
about him
um and very likable and and he was he's
very funny dude he was one of our
favorites too everybody uh and so he
went a little early uh himself uh that
was a tough one um but Chris I think
realized that's what gets you there you
know it's funny on SNL
you you you're you're trying to get a
hook you know you're trying to uh
separate yourself in the 23 cast members
or whatever and uh by the way Nick
Cannon just had his 2014
uh in a related story that just popped
up on him he had his 23rd at last hour
but it is yeah okay and the next one's
in the chamber in the index Circle uh so
so we had all our our people and then
you go I'm trying to be my hook turns
into the sarcastic guy right the
Hollywood minute guy Chris is in fact I
fall down uh Sandler's and then you
spend the rest of your time in SNL
trying to erase it
you know what I mean like you go I
finally got a reason for people to watch
me and then you go well that's not the
only thing I do I go I don't only do
this and they go what else do you do I
go I don't know
nothing
we found out quickly well congrats on it
uh the 25th anniversary of uh Chris's
death with uh Chris Rock Adam Sandler
Conan O'Brien Mike Myers Jim Belushi Bo
Derek oh I remember Bo Derek when she
came to set I was so floored that she
was from the movie 10 and she was like a
international phenomenon like stunner
very sweet I sort of shied away from her
because I was I don't know if pip
squeaks the right word but I was uh an
unfamous pipsqueak so I stayed away is
intimidated of course Farley goes right
in yeah
good good you know I will tell you that
I had a um by the way I'm going to
Milwaukee for my tour next year that's
my first thing in uh January and I've
never been to in some Town Milwaukee
Madison all that stuff so I'm going out
there that'll be that'll be really fun
because those people I have I've always
heard about Milwaukee you know uh anyway
I
oh yeah well I had a foam machine I'll
let you go I know you got to talk about
you know Kyler Murray whatever so um I
uh no those are your Cardinals those
aren't mine listen I know you got a big
segment about turf toe anyway
um would you have hit on Bo Derek if you
were a little bit more established
no because of my sde no
oh you have small figured out small
energy no no but I did his copyright no
but uh I I had a phone machine once not
many guys talk about sde you know like
Pete Davidson is uh no he's got no I
don't think they get they they want the
SD
so hey Kim this is the last story okay
all right all right hurry up I had this
phone machine and a recorder on it and
so I got all my messages from everybody
from SNL when they'd call farther we go
deep speed as I live for free and then
everyone would do like bits Sandler Rock
everyone they call Norm Mike Myers Dana
Dennis and then
I was gonna do something with them all
and then someone uh unplugged it and
erased them all I had them for 10 years
and someone erasable anyway great story
Tyler Murray
by the way uh David's with Ray Romano in
Las Vegas tonight and tomorrow tonight
I'm going right now
what use why you tralala around the
studio I'm out there bus to my home yeah
uh it's great yeah it's great to see you
David Spade